hey guys so pax is this weekend in
Seattle and sadly I am NOT able to make
it but I feel teamed up with Intel to
give you guys a sneak peek at what's
there stay tuned at the end of this
video because I'll let you guys know how
you could enter their contest whether
you're actually at PAX or you're at home
just watching this movie it's a movie
Jenna it's a movie a movie okay go away
cuz I have to tell them something before
okay leave the room okay bye yesterday I
had you guys leave me some comments
because I told you and my sister that we
were gonna do the whisper challenge
which is where someone puts headphones
on they have really loud music and they
can't hear what I'm saying so Jenna
actually cheated and went and read all
of your comments so I'm gonna just kind
of mix things up a little bit and I'm
gonna use some of your comments but I'm
also going to use some of the tech that
is featured in the Intel booth and
whisper it to her and if she guesses any
of this stuff
I will alright I don't know I don't know
what I'll do I'll be extremely impressed
Jenna hello so um are you ready for this
uh yeah okay well I already can't hear
really I didn't turn them on yet perfect
okay what do you want to turn up to huh
are you ready I can't hear Eddie papa
I hear Skrillex am i yelling I just
felix is dealing here I mean like I took
speech path i minored in speech
pathology and I had to take two
semesters of sign language so I
basically passed by lip-reading so you
weren't ready for this
confess you're like
why 50 with 4k display 4k display I've
missed the first one
something novo
I've got an A+ in my sign language class
okay now I'm really mad because I
watched so long okay just play i watch
so many people do this you're using your
big person voice okay sorry I'll turn
down your enunciate I please continue I
want to get an A+ razor blade Alienware
18 18 aliens it's close this is not fun
I do not do this challenge and somebody
has a my Ernst way with knowledge what
was it no what you said alien they're
right I did in 1880 today wins
I said alien we're a team okay I am so
turn who lives in a pineapple under the
sea
pineapples haha spongebob haha pineapple
under the trees oh my god see why would
you be in a tree so Intel is releasing a
new revolutionary chip at PAX pack okay
Dave I'm single then Intel is releasing
a new revolutionary chip at PAX
revolutionary I'm crying I can't
as on my mascara I'm pregnant I have a
tissue to the correct drama here's how
did you fit all that in those jeans
haha how do you fit oh how do you do it
all that them jeans we say that every
day I know I know I see that come on
your mouth all the time do you like your
oat milk Moo they're chunky the way al I
saw was smooth or chunky do you like
your oatmeal smooth or chunky Oh Oh mail
this sucks
I got an a-plus in my glass this is
seriously so louder than terminal Baker
Intel tablets 2 and 1 featuring games
such as beat buddy
two-in-one fishery
it's mom our gun Intel two-in-one
tablets fish fry but featuring games
such as beat buddy hive no idea okay
when you're eating a taco taco yeah did
you say doc I did taco
do you twist your head or the taco all I
heard was taco and head we've turned
down for tacos yeah I just can't believe
you got Lenovo y50 I can't hear you
Intel desktops featuring their new chip
Intel desktops little bit of a vinegar
featuring their new D hearing their new
chips two in one tablet one tablets wait
to tablet two in one tablet just hot air
are you cheating and my Jenna I'm Jenna
are you cheating am i cheating now what
color is my hair what color are your
eyes
nope are you adjusting no I am yeah I am
what did you say come on telling you
tell me I said I forgot
was it close I don't remember what I
said okay
i favorite color is camo your favorite
color is Apple your favorite color is
purple oh yeah this that makes more
sense than apple kammo kammo kammo kammo
huh kim oh that's what it allows the
color okay we're done here cuz yeah I
will never do the whisper challenge with
anybody that has any sort of speech
pathology month so now with the contest
if you guys are not able to make it to
pax all you have to do is create one of
these buttons make it your own and tweet
it to at until USA using the hashtag
Intel at pax and Intel game on did you
get all that did you get all that game
on yeah so you guys can tweet that for a
chance to win a $500 new egg gift
$500 new a gift connive hundred-dollar I
can understand that
but if you actually are a pax just wear
one of these buttons that you can get at
the Intel booth for a chance to win and
now it is time for us to go
I heard coffee and now it's time for us
to go now it's time for us to go this is
this is so unfair
this is unfair this is absolute this is
not fair I did not do that
good job I did not do that well I just
can't believe you got to Lenovo Lenovo
I'm done we're done here I am very I'm
happy that you're so freakin smart still
guys the camera was not a color that's a
pattern I'll see you guys later I wish
that I could make it to pax if you guys
are there I hope you have an awesome
time um that's it I'll see you later bye
I'm gonna wear this all day
Felix is in my Hummer it look like turn
it out I heard out for Skrill i I can't
the beach still in my head
game on